and volition wooden and Morgan phones I
was Californian hello and welcome to a
webcast
Germany Austria Switzerland Stanford
Graduate School of Business and beyond
my name is Tim Eisenman and I'm a second
year MBA student here at the GSB I am
very proud to be graduating in just a
couple of weeks
also pizza I'm joined by dzj pile and
Dominic Faja like me they are from
Germany
their first EMBA students and will
graduate in 2016 we'll be talking about
the student experience here on campus
and answer as many of your questions as
we can including those submitted in
advance we won't be talking about the
admissions process the application or
financial aid you can find these answers
on the Stanford MBA website to submit a
question to us about what it's like to
be a student
just click the chat icon at the top of
your screen enter your question the chat
window and click send to all in your
screen to kick us off I'd suggest that
maybe we introduce ourselves a little
bit so you know who you'll be hearing
from today Desiree would you like to
kick yourself sure
my name is I'm an Emir one student here
at the GSB prior to the GSB I worked in
consulting with the focus on media I did
my undergrad in Switzerland in Zen
garden and after that worked a lot for
various media companies as a journalist
and then later on the business and I'm
very happy to be here to Goosby I'm
excited to talk to you about it today
yes I'm Dominique originally from Munich
I grew up a little bit outside the city
so or countryside mountains outdoors
that's what would I enjoy it
during the youth time and yeah when
you're not outside and you are in the
countryside the first thing that comes
to mind when you don't do that it's like
computers so I always was very attached
to technology I studied computer science
as a result of that studied in Munich
and in Zurich and after that we started
a company in the field of yeah
recruiting the social network so I
worked as a software engineer there and
after we finished up with that company I
work in consulting as well mainly in the
technology space and yeah now I'm here
at the GSB as well as I said already my
name is Tim I'm from Frankfort
originally I used to work in
transportation for Lufthansa one of the
like big German companies in corporate
strategy for two and a half years then
did a lot of Transportation focus here
at the GSB we found a class president of
the travel Hospitality Club and also did
a little bit of work in the social
impact sector in in Africa two very
different things and post GSB I'll be
doing consulting in the airline and
transportation sector as well
well it's maybe they get a head start
and go and answer one of the questions
that would submit it in advance why do
you guys apply to Stanford or Business
School in general what were the driving
factors and and why Stanford in
particular maybe normally do one start
yeah sure yeah I mean for me it's it's
basically the place to be right so I
wanna I wanted to be in the Silicon
Valley because this place is really
where sort of the future gets built this
is where all the big companies all the
ideas come together and Stanford for me
was sort of really central in that
ecosystem and and I think it's a very
special place in that sense that you
find in very few business schools if any
actually so that was was a key driver
for me and it's besides that I was
always sort of torn to that technology
part of it so that made it sort of an
easy choice for me to to to Stanford as
a business school and then you asked
sort of why Business School in general
so so for me was always I come very much
from the technology and engineering side
and and at some point realized that sort
of there's there's a business side as
well to it I learned a little bit of
that in consulting but essentially I saw
like the the very small companies when
when they get started and I saw the
really big companies it's like really
really big ones but I never saw this
place in between and so for me it was
always like how does this go from really
small to scaling it pretty big
part of that is actually scaling
yourself right so how can you scale
yourself as and you have a team of three
people and then suddenly you're a
thousand people or even more like how
can you manage that and a lot of that is
personal skills leadership skills
etcetera and this for me was sort of the
the main driver for Business School in
general so why I chose to apply to a
school I feel like after three years in
consulting I just felt like a [ __ ]
you after some time when you say focus
on one specific topic get pretty good at
it but it's you kind of miss a broader
horizon and I felt that in particular
Stanford would offer that the most to me
in particular looking at the ecosystem
you had the same you talked about it
feels like you're living with I think a
floor and this must have felt like that
in the Renaissance where like everything
is happening exactly in this little tiny
piece of land and it's just exciting to
be here and then more specifically for
me in media and journalism it's hugely
disrupt the industry's future disruptive
at the moment buy a lot of things which
are going on here and so I was just very
excited to learn about it and to know it
does take a little bit of more
convincing and telling other people
though because Business School isn't
that commonly known as a career path in
Germany in the u.s. it's a bit different
but it does bring us closer to our goals
at least when I speak for myself
maybe we can add on to a Jew said easily
about being here in ecosystem of
entrepreneurship while having a very
strong background in in media how as the
GSB helped you get closer to what you
want to do after so I can come in here I
knew that there is the arts media
entertainment Club for example which I
am the president of right now and we're
just doing a lot of things in in in the
school kind of bringing media executive
here talking and your company is here to
talk about what's going on in the
industry then furthermore there are a
bunch of classes which are kind of
hugely tailored to exactly that space so
there's one about leadership and
entertainment I'm taking another one
actually not at the
it's cool but on campus and Stanford
which is called entrepreneurial media
and so we are kind of in that class
already working in teams and working on
business ideas and pitching it to
investors this Friday actually I'm
trying to figure out whether we have
found something which is interesting and
so overall I think the GSB is helping me
also personally to look at all these
different spaces it's very easy to
actually contact people and get them to
talk to you about these things and so
it's been kind of from clubs from the
classes but then also from people who
come to the juice be in topic I mean the
at stanford.edu email address opens any
door you want and Dominic is casually
starting his own company yeah sure and
and also like I fully agree with what
Desiree said I mean um for me was never
really a traditional career path post
GSB so I never had that in mind and
there's a lot of classmates who have
that if for example if you go into
banking is that right it's a it's a very
clear path and that for me was never
never the case and not part of making
the decision towards I'm going to
business school but it's all those other
elements that come together and I think
that makes a key difference from the GSB
so first of all there is this the
network that you get right then access
you get to people so for example I'm in
a class with Peter Levine right now
who's the enterprise software partner
from andreessen horowitz just like it's
probably the best we see that you can
find out there right and so you really
have access and very close connection to
those people and it's it's really
tremendous and as Tim said where we're
sort of starting our own business right
now and yeah if you have access to those
people and then really can can have a
casual chat with them and ask them
certain questions that you have it just
makes a huge difference right and and
this is sort of the thing then you get
the introduction and then you get the
next step and and most of the stuff that
you actually try to do you're right at
the center of what where customers are
where the ideas get sparked you get all
this inspiration from others
schools as like it's just a five-minute
walk in you in computer science right
which is probably also the best computer
science department in the world so it's
it's really it all comes together and
this weird thing of ecosystem and in a
non-traditional career paths I think
this is what makes the makes a
difference and that you have access to
all of those opportunities and just can
go into it one thing I just want to add
is that even if you have a particular
interest such as media I know if they
are in biotech the GSB does offer a lot
of classes already but then across the
street and basically all the other
faculties Stanford GSB students can take
classes as well so there are a couple of
classmates that have only taken the the
minimum of GSB classes and taken
advantage of all the across the street
classes a lot of people take the basic
coding Club ace coding class just so
they know how to speak with with
technical co-founders um let's maybe
pivot to some of the questions that were
submitted right now
how has the the different education
style us versus german-speaking
countries played out for you guys what
were the major differences so I think
for me it was just sighs even though I
studied a small university classes were
still massively huge so here we have
classes from 20 to 70 people and it's
even smaller it lasts 12 yeah 12 and
it's it's fascinating and it's
fascinating to have kind of everybody
participating a lot more and that's also
something you have to get used to it's
it's kind of much more interactive
people are expecting you to speak up it
slightly different than then and back
and where I studied but then also I
think we've been educated to not be as
controversial when we kind of make
statements and things like that the
discussions don't come up that easily
but this is entirely different here and
people just speak their minds and
there's always an interesting and
gashing going on in the classroom yeah
let's maybe you have you talked about
how you make the most out of what's
happening on campus I mean there's so
many activities
what do you prioritize wasn't
overwhelming at first and how have you
managed to do that definitely
overwhelming the thing is you can do
whatever you want right so there's if
you're curious about things there's
there's everything going on and so one
of the things for me coming in was to
sometimes not do the smart things but
the sort of more interesting and
curiosity driven things and you can do
what whatever you want basically so if
there's a session on virtual reality you
just learn more about virtual reality or
all those crazy things that are going on
and sort of the edges and that
oftentimes you don't have access to when
you're not in a university context and
so this is sort of the curiosity part
for me and in the other part with
resources is when you when you think
about actually a business and starting
something there's tremendous resources
available from events to personal
coaching's to sort of classes where you
can actually learn those things directly
and you get mentors that that help you
with cetera and yeah so at the end of
the day I remember when when we started
you basically leave your home at 8
o'clock and then you come back at 10
o'clock you you were like busy the whole
day for me was more busy than than
during when I was working that means
Dominic does not go out and party as if
he comes home at 10 a.m. yeah yeah he's
a boring software engineer yeah but but
that's about it you you go to bed maybe
you party maybe you don't but you you go
to bed and you're sort of it's this
happy sort of stress right so you you
just feel like there was so much going
on and you feel like so awesome but at
the same time it's this good sort of
exhaustion and yeah and sometimes you
need to prioritize but my my thing was
always to keep more the filter open and
take in as much as possible the other
way around I would totally agree with
that in particular this idea that you
kind of just get everything kind of
Lombard at you but on the other is your
own stress so prior and consulting is
always like a partner and giving you
stress
kindness but right now it's like all
about you and if you can decide
everything and it's incredibly
energizing that's right one of the
questions is came in asked about the the
background of your classmates a whole
bunch of them I international is just
like us
there of course a lot of classmates in
South America a lot from Asia Central
Europe as well I think in my class be a
lot of Germans French Spanish students
but it varies I mean there is no set
amount of people that come from a
specific country it really depends on on
the application pool of that specific
year but maybe you can talk about some
classmates that have been especially
inspiring and have had a really
interesting professional background so I
think for me there are there we have
musical stars people who like we're on
American Idol for example and they have
the most beautiful voices and incredible
artistic talent Rich's we have a big
show every year but people kind of
produce a one time musical and it's
perfect as professional as you would see
in Broadway and that was something which
I didn't even expect coming here and as
incredibly impressed then right now I
just come out of a classroom where
somebody talked about their operations
experience at Formula One and how he for
seven years worked as a manager and
general manager in the Middle East for
the Formula One team huge fan obviously
but it's just entirely different than a
lot of others I think I can think of
like yeah I mean the same and for for me
what what was pretty interesting was
talking to people who were in the
military before which is something that
was really not present whatsoever before
in sort of the European education and
like really hearing how they experienced
their lives before whatever happened I
mean you can hardly imagine it just
gives you a lot of perspective right and
and that happens to all the
sorts of people like we have
professional poker players
whatsoever it's it's it's really
interesting in essentially it's
different perspectives on on things you
you had in mind before and you just
challenged it and maybe just to give it
so we have each week we have to shaft
classmates actually sharing their story
and sharing their entire lives with us
within 30 minutes talk it's every Monday
for the FA ones and it's kind of that's
the moment where you get to know them
and you know so much more about where
they come from the life they've been
living before what has shaped them who
they are today and it's kind of a very
inspiring you get to know you know at
first it's a lot of hey what have you
been doing where you're from what did
you beforehand and then the GSB I think
finds good ways to connect people in
small or more meaningful settings talk
is one of them but there are tons of
small group dinners that are actually
supported by the university's
financially there are wind groups will
come together and talk about their
experience and maybe more male dominated
environments or at business school and
then of course the club's a season as
you mentioned does host a variety of
events with people that have a similar
interest so they didn't get to know each
other on a deeper level and then all the
outside stuff like I've actually gotten
to know more people play tennis and with
any any other thing and I mean beyond
that I think it's not just those kinds
of event but also that the class size is
small in general right so I mean we are
400 people roughly yeah for me it was
from you it was something that you can
actually get to know 400 people quite
well right and versus if it would be a
thousand or more people I I'm not sure I
can get to know each and every one in
that sense and you always have this
moment of where you actually want to get
to know everyone and hear those stories
whatsoever and I think 400 people is the
size for you
you have enough interaction on a regular
basis yeah that works
so let's dial back for you guys probably
a year and a half you were thinking
about applying to business school how
did you know that that was the right
time
was it the right time for me there was
no such question actually like I I
didn't particularly design this process
of now it's the time to you know I never
crossed my mind in that sense I always
had this notion in mind that I need to
sort of get back I need the time to sort
of develop those more leadership more
long-term oriented skills especially
from a empathy people perspective and I
think Business School is a good place to
do that and especially the focus that
the GSB kids on some of this empathetic
leadership and leadership development I
think is it's a good thing about that
and it just felt right and trim self I
want to do the next step but I never
specifically designed a timeline and
where it was what's right so yeah what
are you for you because I think for us
in a more traditional kind of consulting
path and it's gonna suggest it to you
would you so I was very fed up with my
job
I learned a ton and had great colleagues
but it was a very hierarchical you know
German corporate environment and I was
basically told I'm doing a great job but
in order to take on more responsibility
I have to do the same job for the five
years maybe with a different title but
basically the same thing and there were
a bunch of options on the table either
you know changing jobs or going to
business school um I decided that I
would give it a shot Harvard or Stanford
because I figured that if I spent that
much money I might as well do it on on
one of those schools that have a huge
brand recognition and then what that
worked out well and and then I figured I
would I would come in and do it so
similar to Dominic I hadn't mapped it
out had it not worked I might have spend
another year at my job I have might have
gone to a different business school but
um it was I did not have the five year
plan so let's move to another question
from from the audience that's actually
interesting also how has the Stanford
experience been different to what you
what you guys expected is there anything
you you did not come see besides the
fact that there are opera musical stars
in the class um I think for me what has
surprise me is that how much kind of
social activity so for me I think I'm an
introvert by nature and just like coming
here and the way how much there is and
how much there is to experience how much
energy that actually takes I've never I
think I've never experienced as many
dinners as many parties as many
everythings and so it's kind of a very
intense environment I'm not only from a
kind of school perspective and
everything else was going on in your
mind but also socially and that was it's
a it's a happy surprise because it's
wonderful but it's also it also takes a
lot of energy and kind of great space to
think about how all of us social
activity kind of comes together agree
what was surprising for me is we talked
about it before it actually rains in
California twice a year and those two
days I've been the last to know actually
has been funny I was I was actually
surprised how how cool people are
because what you think about Business
School you think of that as being one of
the puzzle pieces in your professional
life but I think also the personal life
it has shaped me a lot because it gives
you two years to breathe take a step
back look at what you've done look at
who you are and look at what you want to
do after and I thought it would be a way
to like acquire some more tools in order
to be a better manager but but I think
the introspection the level of
self-reflection in the time I have was
was pretty impressive and one class in
particular that we have to basically
talk about is touchy-feely interpersonal
dynamics that easily has taken a
dominate not yet so so he does not know
what we're talking about what it
basically is is I think 12 people or 16
people 12 people in a room with our
instructions script anything -
facilitators but basically 12 people
sitting next to each other and having
nothing to talk about and then you start
talking about you know things for
example I might
hey should we talk about you know norms
and went to and to arrive for class and
then Desiree might tell me well champ by
you asking that question you implicitly
took on a leadership role in this class
and I'm not comfortable I don't feel
comfortable with that you get feedback
on your actions life and in a way you
usually don't get it in our work
environment yeah that actually speaks to
one of the questions around kind of how
to develop your soft skills and know
more about your strengths and weaknesses
and it's phenomenal because so I'm just
in the class tomorrow and where we share
like the final feedback which is
basically five hours of feedback to 12
people in a room and it's only one kind
of small piece of it in general we spend
a lot of time during that class sitting
around together just learning about each
other learning what actually works what
does and what works for you how do you
react to things you just get a lot more
self-aware and know what works for you
but you also learn a lot about how other
people interact and kind of trying to
hone your skills of how to actually work
in groups and how that works I thought
it was a kind of phenomenal experience
when it comes to soft skills but there
are also a lot of others so maybe you
want to leader yeah and I think in
general even even beyond that that's
just one element but what was surprising
for me is like how deliberately the GSB
actually shapes culture right and you
spend a lot of time talking about norms
and and how people interact together in
all of those different sessions and
courses come together and you sort of
you develop a culture in and for me it
was really surprising to see that it's
almost like you engineer a certain
culture right and in this openness
vulnerability feedback etc it feels
almost like a DNA of the GSB and and
like we've been through the first year
right and then now it seems like almost
we're sort of got that DNA and and we
feel comfortable with it and then sort
of live it ourselves so I think that's
yeah and I'm almost worried to go back
to the real world and experience
everybody's not as vulnerable and open
and sharing and caring
yeah yeah I think it's it's a very
special environment and there's certain
things you can take back into the real
world and some things you might want to
keep for yourself I'm talking about the
about the real world what are you guys
gonna do over the summer maybe you could
talk about the recruiting process for
for summer internships were you guys
gonna head out in like two weeks
yeah stay here I'm gonna stay here so I
cannot talk too much about recruiting
process maybe you can a little bit after
that but yeah we're using this summer
and this very specific three-month
period to to actually start a business
in the insurance base I'm so we're
trying to use technology and insurance
and and build something around that and
yeah I think that's sort of felt like
the the first year for me was taking a
step back learning a lot of new things
but also building out a team to do that
right and so one of the team members
actually from the from the GSB right now
and it it sort of was this whole ramping
up period for that and so instead of
recruiting we sort of did a business
plan and whatsoever say we substitute
that yeah but for the summer I'm
actually staying here in Palo Alto and
yeah we're starting business year so I
I'm a B took a more traditional
recruiting path there are a bunch of
on-campus recruiting events companies
coming to campus talking talking about
their recruiting process and then
starting that that process mainly big
corporates from the US some from Europe
consulting companies finance companies
that is you know that the on-campus
recruiting then there is gonna come
smaller SME recruiting one of the key
events at the GSB is the fewer than 300
event or companies that have you know
less than 300 employees come to campus
and it's very informal casual setting
and you you get to talk to up-and-coming
company's event pride and those kind of
companies usually Tech in the valley and
then there's networking based recruiting
so you can meet with Career Management
employees and they help you kind of find
people that work in this
face that you wanna you wanna be in and
in connect you directly I'm given that
the class size is fairly small with 400
the community is is very strong so even
if people you know 20 years before you
graduate and are now in an interesting
position they will usually return your
email or your call and get back to you
and I see where we're almost running out
of time they've been by quickly for more
minutes to go before we go Dominique
Daisy any words of final advice for the
people that are thinking about applying
to Stanford and your GSB highlight in
your number one ladies first I guess in
terms of advice I would say fighting
through this whole application process
and through the GMAT and all of that is
a lot of work and it's kind of stressful
especially for me it was like stressful
period doing that next to your job but
it's incredibly worth it and you this
time here has been one of the most
amazing of my life and so I'm incredibly
thankful and we just want to tell you
that it's gonna be like coming out of
this whole process you're gonna be here
and it's it's wonderful what's the most
amazing moment for me I think there have
been yes same here I think I just do it
it's probably a good yeah I think people
tell you that the application process
itself is valuable for me back then it
was sort of I couldn't believe that but
it actually is in a certain way because
it forces you to reflect yourself forces
you to engage also the people you ask
for a recommendation on a very sort of
deeper feedback conversation and sort of
get all of those things together so I
think just to
it is probably the right thing for me to
say and when it comes to a favorite
moment it's hard to pinpoint because
there's this actually so much happening
like it feels like one day of GSB is
probably like a week well I play with
dogs but I think what was really cool
experience in general is of the GST what
we do here so we have to do this global
study trips I took the global route to
the US actually but it's sort of this
study trip where you actually get to
know a country deeper and better and
you're in a group of 2030 people roughly
you have a lot of meetings with
professionals with politicians industry
leaders to get us sort of the culture
but you also get to know your peers
really well I think this GST experience
for me was was pretty cool and I mean we
had phenomenal meetings like we've been
to New York for example where we met
Michael Bloomberg and you have a pretty
intense and open discussion with with
those people and for me this was my
piece of advice be yourself
really showcase what makes you different
and don't talk about you know what makes
you similar to a lot of people that
might have gone to the GSB the class
aims to be as diverse as possible so
whatever makes his special should
definitely be in the application and my
highlight was in my first year um I had
been working in Rwanda and I had the
chance to have lunch with Paul Kagame
the President of Rwanda which was really
interesting getting to speak to a person
like that um one on one and I think
that's basically it thank you so much
Daisy and Dominic for joining us this
morning and thanks to all of you for
participating if you'd like to hear more
about the GSB you can meet an MBA
admissions officer in person while they
travel to many cities throughout Europe
this summer I believe Germany Austria
Switzerland are probably amongst their
route please keep an eye out for the
invitations to meet them or check the
events page on the Stanford MBA website
you can also learn more about the MBA
program admissions requirements and
financial aid on the website application
for the class starting in the fall of
2016
will be available in June finally please
take a moment to answer a few survey
questions about your experience with us
today
once the webcast ends click the ok
button on the pop-up window and you will
be directed to matically to the survey
thanks again have a great day oh he does
it